the wolf of wallstreet so the wolf of
wall street's directed by Martin
Scorsese it stars Leonardo DiCaprio and
Scorsese telling a story about this guy
who works Wall Street and then builds
his own shady ass company and does stock
trading makes millions of dollars not
all of it legal of course and gives us
an entertaining ass movie that's three
hours long and like in Gilligan's Island
this is a three-hour tour filled with
twists turns and crashes and some really
good writing
first of all Leonardo DiCaprio in the
leading role kills in this movie this
dude like I've always said it's one of
the best actors in the business he gets
snubbed for an Oscar every year killed
it in Django Unchained kills it in this
movie will it get nominated I don't know
will he win I have no idea doesn't
matter not at all because he is still
badass in this movie and that's what
matters he plays a silver-tongued devil
who's just really good at this industry
because he is good at speaking anytime
DiCaprio has a microphone and a crowd
take note she's want to listen to be
like America of america yeah
america yeah America America this
is awesome this is why a lot of
countries hate America but this is why I
love it Merrick he's so energetic you
feel energized you just like his
ambition you're like you know what this
is great seeing your empire grow it's
bag he's a dick he's an for sure
but he's so ambitious you can't help but
be on board with his endeavor
you know Gordon Gekkos greed is good
monologue in wall street dicaprio has a
few monologues in the wolf of wallstreet
that are every bit as good the
supporting actors were awesome also I
mean Jonah Hill was great in this movie
Jonah Hill has become like the new
DiCaprio kind of like DiCaprio he was
that guy that sprung on the scene I'm
like yeah yeah he's good I mean whatever
and now your life is just a force to be
reckoned with he's a great actor
seriously Jonah Hill was hilarious
DiCaprio was hilarious this movie is
really funny in that really misogynistic
kind of way almost an American Psycho
Wall Street kind of way DiCaprio even
makes the point in this movie where he's
like I live this lavish life and make
sure my troops see it because I want
them to aspire to have the life I have
it drives them in that same sense this
movie is doing the same
do you you're watching it you're like
yeah I'm visual you know what listen
let's get a business plan together let's
be like that Martin Scorsese has given
us the most relevant thing for the
economy in the past decade this movie is
gratuitous for sure the second scene you
see in the movies DiCaprio blowing
cocaine up a girl's ass like oh okay so
it's gonna be like that that's what you
do with your Titanic money I get it
don't worry I'm sure James Cameron did
the same thing someone like Game of
Thrones really like it's clearly the
most gratuitous thing I've seen in a
while but is it relevant for the story
actually is DiCaprio is such a silver
tongue devil you can argue that he is
like the devil himself this movie is a
big illustration of Babylon you know you
need to see that where it's like we can
get anything and we have everything
we're elect to our own devices no chains
at all now the movie is three hours long
the first two-thirds of this movie was
my favorite part because you know that's
his climb it's his ambition you see the
drive it's like social network I like
that movie because I like seeing things
get built the last third of the movies a
little different not that it's bad in
terms of story arcs perfectly fine I'm
just saying in terms of personal
preference I like the first two-thirds
better I can definitely tell you the
movie never seemed like three hours long
for sure I've watched two hour-long
movies that seemed a lot longer than
wolf of wallstreet this movie constantly
kept me entertained for sure and
DiCaprio's voice-over makes you feel
like he's talking to you and he's taking
you along for this ride you feel like
his apprentice or his protege or
something you feel like you're under the
wing of the Dragon and it is warm my
friends this movie is really high octane
and really fast to an ADHD degree it
helps you feel the momentum of the life
they live for sure and I like that but
I'm sure they're gonna be people like
they're gonna be like it's just too
jarring and too fast for me not gonna
lie in school I was never much of a math
person but I like the practical
application of math you want practical
math here it is American Psycho
plus Wall Street Times Pulp Fiction
equals the wolf of Wall Street
I say pulp fiction because of the
monologue aspect this movies really
quotable like pulp fiction was I feel
like it's the pulp fiction of this
decade when you combine movies like that
I'm simply trying to tell you one thing
my friends the wolf of Wall Street is
awesome tacular
mmm-hmm I already did that it's still
fun to do right so the wolf of
wallstreet have you seen it what did you
think about it if you haven't what's
your favorite Scorsese movie so far
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more